in the real world what you see is
usually what you get this code this
cylinder and the stuffed horse are all
inanimate objects but what if you could
unleash some childhood fantasies and
make them move on their own new research
out of Yale University can make that a
reality viable robotic skins can be
wrapped around soft bodied objects
giving them the ability to bend creep
even trot along like a blood-pressure
cuff the skin covers the object with an
elastic or fabric material over tiny
pressurized strips of electronic
actuators or more simply air valves but
while a blood pressure cuff squeezes
with the same horse in all directions
the robotic skin pushes at different
speeds in different places
these pushes give this frame and canvas
ball or your favorite childhood toy the
ability to walk Wabble researchers
didn't stop at using these skins to
simply move objects they outfitted one
cylinder with a camera and adjusted its
skin so it can crawl along like an
inchworm such warm BOTS can be used in
rescue operations and for exploring tiny
spaces that humans are just too big to
enter the robotic skins on this person's
back can detect bad posture and alert
them the possibilities are endless but
that's kind of the point
researchers have high hopes of using
this handy technology in places where
one object might need to do the task a
mini like outer space currently it costs
millions to send payloads to Mars and
the International Space Station
if robotic skins can help repurpose
out-of-date tools they could save space
programs a bundle meanwhile it never
hurts to dream
[Music]